the more vulnerable records or at least
you know in my opinion was the record
with jt yeah shout out to jt shout out
big shout out jt uh that's gotta be a
bucket list thing right huge all-time
great all-time great caucasian that jt
fourth quarter some might say jack
harlow's all-time great caucasian right
yeah man i wouldn't be mad at that um
but yeah what like so that was one of
the last records like snuck in during
mastering
insane
that's crazy yeah so like
literally i mean that song is not three
weeks old like the song is new that's
crazy yeah so what was it before was it
just a reference because obviously you
had those verses together i'm sure i
mean i did those verses late
i just love that beat and i just was
venting on it and then but it didn't
have a chorus
so we presented it to him and he laid it
down in front of me he smacked it in
front of you yeah wow yeah was it fast
like yeah that's crazy yeah shout out to
jt man massive shout out video
we'll see